Now that we've gone over Blueprints, we're next going to take a look really quickly at
Unreal Motion Graphics or UMG to understand more about what it is as we're going to be
using this tool with the accompanying workshop.
So what is UMG?
Well UMG or Unreal Motion Graphics is a visual UI authoring tool that can be used to create
UI elements such as in-game HUDs, menus, or other interface related graphics you wish
to present to your users.
You can use UMG to create menus, full screens, or pop-ups, HUDs, and even 3D displays.
Right here is an image of the UMG editor and the editor itself is actually broken up into
a couple of different tools.
There's two different tools.
There's the designer which we see right here.
The designer is broken up into the following little areas here.
Over one, we have the palette.
This is where we're going to find all of the pre-built UI elements that we want to work
with.
So the great thing about this is that we can pull in something like a generic button and
either use the existing imagery or bring in all of our own imagery.
This is really handy because we don't actually have to worry about building code to make
a button.
We simply just bring in different common UI elements like buttons and images and sliders
and things like that.
And then we can use those to do things in our UI.
Underneath our palette here, we have our hierarchy which is going to show us the hierarchy
of this UI.
So if we have a bunch of buttons here, it will show us the buttons.
And if we have things nested underneath those buttons, it will show us what those items
are.
In the middle, this is going to be our UI preview area.
What we do with our UMG widgets is we bring these common elements in to three right here
and then we can place them around the scene in order to make them more in line with our
UI needs.
Finally, or I shouldn't say finally, but next we have four, which is our details panel.
The details panel is context sensitive.
So that means that based on what we have selected, the details inside of here are going to be
different.
But this is how we modify the properties of these common elements that we put inside of
our UI right here.
Last but not least is number five, which is our animations.
This allows us to animate objects.
So if I was to click on this, we'd get a little animation window coming up.
And while we're not going to be utilizing this in today's tutorial, it is nice to know
that we can fully animate all of our UI elements, their positions, but we can also animate their
visibility or we can make them fly up and then get bigger or smaller.
Lots of cool things that we can do with that.
Now the second part of our tool is called the graph.
So I like to refer to them like this.
The designer is how we make our UI pretty.
The graph is how we make our UI functional.
If you notice that this actually looks very similar to a blueprint, and that's because
you are actually using blueprints to build your UI.
So over here under the my blueprint, this is we're going to find different functions that
we have built or right now we're seeing preexisting functions in there.
Or we can also override and add variables and things like that.
Two is our details panel.
And again, this is context sensitive.
So based on what we have selected, the details is going to be different.
And then three is our event graph.
This is going to work exactly the same like the event graph does inside of blueprints.
We're going to put down various nodes inside of here.
And then based off of the events that happen when those nodes are clicked on, we will then
do things.
So for example, if we were to be inside of our, I'm going to click back to our designer
here.
Inside of our designer, we could put something like a button here.
And then on that button, we're going to have a little behavior that says on clicked.
And when we press that, we'll see that inside of our event graph here, we'll have a little
on clicked that will allow us to then execute some code.
So this might look overwhelming or a little daunting.
Do not worry.
You're going to see how easy these tools are to use and how much blueprints and UMG all
have together.
And our workshop, which are going to start right after this slide.